So we said that the SMT processor
is not that much more expensive
than a single threaded processor that
has the same issue within everything.
Let's see what the hardware changes for
SMT look like so
that we can convince ourselves that it's
indeed not that much more expensive.
In a normal processor, we would have
a program counter that we use to access
the instruction cache to
fetch our instructions.
Because this is a super
scalar processor,
we are fetching more than just one
instruction with this program counter.
Then we get into a decoder that
is capable of decoding multiple
instructions per cycle.
Then a renamer that gets to read and
update the RAT for this thread.
And once the instructions is renamed it
gets to the reservation stations, and
then from here we send the instructions
for execution, and in our ROB,
we need to track what's the next
committed instruction from this thread.
So if we want to add the ability
to simultaneously multi-thread
another thread here.
We definitely need a separate PC here.
And we need a logic that will
fetch from these two PCs.
We could do this every cycle we fetch,
from both of the PCs,
half of the instructions.
Or we can actually do one cycle fetch
everything you can from this PC,
one cycle fetch everything
you can from this PC.
So SMT usually refers to
what's happening here,
but here we could actually be doing fine
grain multithreading as far as fetching
is concerned.
Most processors that do SMT
actually do it that way.
Decoding is completely oblivious to
where the instructions came from.
So we don't really need to change
anything about our decoding logic.
The renamer, does the same thing
regardless of where the instruction came
from, except that the RATs
accesses needs to be different.
So now we have two RATs,
one for each thread.
That we need to access depending
on what we're renaming.
After renaming, instructions got
separate physical registers for
each thread.
So the reservation stations
are simply shared by the two threads.
The execution units get to execute
the operations with the values
they are given so they have no clue
where the instruction really came from.
And then when we get to the ROB,
we need to either have a separate ROB
with its own commit point in which case
each of the threads gets to
commit each instruction in order.
Or we actually put all the instructions
in interleaved order in the ROB,
in which case we will not be
able to commit an instruction
from one thread until all
the instructions from it and
the other thread that
preceded have been committed.
Because the ROB is a large In complex
piece of hardware, typically we don't do
this and we actually suffer, here,
by just committing the threads together.
But if we have sent the instructions, in
order, to the reservation stations and
their ROB, then the order in
the ROB is still the correct order.
It's just at sometimes we could have
committed a instruction from one thread,
but we have to wait for the other
thread to also commit some instructions
before that, so it's slightly less
optimal, but still works fine.
The thing that happens at commit though,
is that we deposit the results into
the architectural register file.
And also when we send instructions for
execution, we send it along with
the data, that comes from the ARF,
our threads do have different registers.
Our zero here is not
the same as our zero here.
So we need a separate ARF and a separate
path to each of the ARFs here and
also the separate read ports here.
So as you can see,
the complexity largely
lies in having multiple pieces and being
able to fetch from either of them and
in the logic that immediately
precedes the reservation stations.
But the really complicated part of
the processor which is the reservation
stations, the broadcast of results and
so on, stays the same.
So this is why the cost is not
twice the cost of the processor.
Most of the cost of the processor
is in the cache right here,
the complex hardware here, the large
ROB where you can insert things and
wait for them to finish and so on and
commit, and also the data cache.
And what you're really adding is another
PC here, same size cache as before,
another RAT, another ARF, but
keep the complex part alone.
So that's why the cost is not very,
very high.